c'est donc ce bois en bordure de l'a6
sur la commune de saint cyr les colons
dans l'yonne que les fouilles ont été
menées des fouilles pour tenter de
retrouver le corps de marie angèle
domèce l'une des victimes de michel
fourniret
la jeune femme de 19 ans avait disparu
en 1988 jusqu'en milieu d'après midi les
gendarmes de la section de recherches de
dijon fouillé une partie de cette forêt
différents barrages ont été installés
pourquoi précisément ici rien n'a filtré
les recherches n'ont pas abouti cette
opération s'inscrit dans la continuité
des aveux de michel fourniret
le mois dernier il a reconnu avoir tué
marie angèle domèce ainsi qu'une autre
jeune femme la britannique joanne à
paris à la fin des années 80 le tueur en
série avait vécu dans une maison sur
cette commune de saint cyr les colons
on ne sait pour l'instant pas si
d'autres recherches sont prévues sur le
secteur michel fourniret avait été
condamné à la perpétuité en 2008 pour
les meurtres de sept autres jeunes
femmes